since its inception in 2008 the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has provided some of
the biggest and best moments in film but
not every Marvel movie is part of the
MCU and the ones that aren't are often
terrible here's a countdown of the 10
crappiest movies starring Marvel
characters going from best of the worst
to the worst of the worst the third and
final installment of Sam Raimi's
original spider-man trilogy has one
thing going for it it's the least bad of
the very worst Marvel movies overstuffed
with too many characters and plot lines
2007's spider-man 3 also veered straight
into camp with some truly weird and
hokey scenes and the best parts are
basically just rehashes of better
moments from the first two spider-man
films watching this it's pretty easy to
understand why the studio rebooted the
franchise a solo Wolverine movie
starring the beloved Hugh Jackman seemed
like a no brainer
and that's exactly what 2009's x-men
origins Wolverine had no brains
for instance the decision to include
Deadpool but literally sew his mouth
shut so he couldn't make jokes deprived
the character of you know his only
actual purpose for existing and the rest
of the film was even less fun with an
unrelenting league grim and tedious slog
through Logan's backstory this is one of
the rare cases where the first entry in
the trilogy was by far the worst just
ask Ryan Reynolds
don't scratch cleaning up the fine lines
speaking of movies that just aren't fun
angley's 2003 examination of Bruce
banners tortured psyche was kind of the
opposite of a summer popcorn movie Lee's
Hulk also featured some very iffy CGI at
a time when the technology clearly
wasn't ready to do what they needed it
to do
Eric Bana did fine in the lead role but
the best thing that can be said for this
one is that its failure helped pave the
way for Marvel to get the film rights
back to the Hulk before Chris Evans
played Captain America he was the
arrogant yet suave Johnny Storm in the
first two installments of the Fantastic
Four franchise so it's just as well the
2007's rise of the Silver Surfer was
such a dud that they never made and
released a third film otherwise Evans
wouldn't have been able to play Captain
America what was so bad about it
well beyond the boring CGI Silver Surfer
himself the movie featured a terrible
version of Doctor Doom and an even worse
version of Galactus he should have been
even scarier than Thanos but instead he
was a giant cosmic space part that's
gross
before Wonder Woman and Captain Marvel
hit the scene the comic book movie world
was severely lacking in female led films
why well the craptacular 2005 sloth
Elektra is a big reason nominally a
spin-off of the 2003 film daredevil
Elektra featured Jennifer Garner gamely
wading through a convoluted and tedious
plot about an assassin for hire it was
kind of like John wick they except
really bad in just about every way it
turned a generous 11 percent critical
rating on Rotten Tomatoes and absolutely
bombed at the box office
convincing Hollywood for the next decade
that fans didn't want to see movies
about female superheroes but we did we
really did we just wanted those movies
to be you know good the 2007 stink bomb
Ghost Rider might not even make the top
ten worst Nic Cage films but it's right
up there with the worst Marvel movies
ever how bad is it signs pointed
terrible
[Music]
some would argue that the sequel is even
worse but since that never would have
existed without this thing
the original still gets lower marks
thankfully fans of the ghostwriter
character finally got a decent version
when he appeared on the TV series agents
of shield seriously just watch that
instead calling the 2015 reboot a
fantastic Forex trainwreck is a gross
disservice to wrecked trains director
Josh Trank and the execs at Fox
reportedly clashed over the film from
day one they were allegedly so unhappy
with what he delivered that the studio
commissioned rewrites and reshoots
without his involvement Trank claims
they ruined his film while other reports
claimed he was disruptive and erratic on
set the film was such a colossal failure
in every way the Disney allegedly fired
tranq from a planned Star Wars spin-off
based just on what they had heard about
Fantastic Four before it was even
released ouch
adults today who can recall seeing
Howard the Duck when they were kids
might be surprised upon watching it now
just how creepy this movie truly is and
not just for the scene where an
anthropomorphic duck has adult relations
with Lea Thompson maybe it's not a man
you should be looking for
you think I might find happiness in the
animal kingdom ducky no there's plenty
of other creepy stuff in this one too
which explains why this was such a
massive box office disaster still Howard
the Duck has it's cult followers which
explains why the character has made
cameos and MCU films like both guardians
of the galaxy movies and Avengers
endgame and why Thompson herself has
talked about making a new Howard the
Duck movie what a strange world we live
in
long before samuel l.jackson donned the
eyepatch and played Nick Fury for the
MCU Marvel's top secret agent was played
by another famous face David Hasselhoff
yes the Baywatch star and international
singing sensation played the lead in the
1998 TV movie Nick Fury agent of shield
it featured incredible lines of dialogue
such as this I'll get that vampire's
blood of Alice
to say this version of fury was a
disaster is an understatement it earned
dismal 16 percent audience score on
Rotten Tomatoes and the series that the
movie was meant to launch never went
forward there's one person who thinks it
was good though David Hasselhoff who
told movie Lyon in 2012 I love Sam
Jackson but you know my Nick Fury was
the organic Nick Fury that was written
and discussed with Stanley before anyone
got in there to change it
score one for free world here it is the
worst of the worst
1990s Captain America which was so bad
its theatrical run was cancelled before
I could ever hit theaters starring Matt
Salinger son of reclusive author JD
Salinger this cinematic loaf has earned
a lowly seven percent critics score and
a 16 percent audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes why
well the production values are
non-existent the red skull was switched
from German to Italian for no apparent
reason and Captain America The Sentinel
of Liberty himself twice stitches his
friends by pretending to be violently
carsick would you please pull over the
car I am going to get sick
are you okay all right all of America
thanks you Chris Evans check out one of
her newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your Marvel
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you